our series of more perfect union names
to show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us the
pandemic of course is stressful for
almost all of us that includes frontline
workers
and service members many soldiers face
serious additional challenges after
repeated deployments overseas
well now there's one group getting
military members veterans and first
responders
back on the track jamie wax shows us how
they're finding help
behind the wheel
[Music]
here near houston veterans are on the
fast track to rebuilding their lives
i remember going man today was amazing
and i want more of that
three marine deployments left ryan
fogarty facing depression
and ptsd you're talking about the killer
of the human soul and often the human
life absolutely
if i got to ride the world's greatest
roller coaster i lived my childhood
dream
and when you don't have that anymore you
just don't feel a purpose you don't feel
worthy
now he's finding purpose with the help
of the unique non-profit
usmc racing started by a fellow marine
brian czech to help struggling vets meet
up
and shift their healing into high gear
they get out of the car
they're like shaking from adrenaline
they're smiling ear to ear
it's amazing how healing that adrenaline
can be it's unbelievable the usmc in the
nonprofit's name doesn't stand for u.s
marine corps
but uncle sam's misguided children
reflecting how some returning servicemen
and women see themselves while adjusting
to life back here at home
it's a group of guys getting a car
running and getting out in the track and
doing your part in order to accomplish
your mission
feels familiar to you absolutely and to
everyone who races in this
and we all feel that camaraderie and
having that purpose
reclaiming that purpose is personal for
check
i have buried more friends due to
suicide
i've seen more guys go to jail drinking
problems
i got sick of seeing it and i felt like
i needed to do something and with almost
18 veterans a day
taking their lives something more than
just spinning his wheels
making people aware of something to me
that's that's kind of a cop
out we're actually out here doing this
yeah but this is no race to the cure
like the process of helping vets it's a
test of endurance
and teamwork all right go ahead in
relays that can run
24 hours straight called 24 hours of
limits
that's lemons because well look at them
squeezing all that's left out of these
junkyard jewels
when you're right up in it you get a
sense of the speed of these cars
once called halloween meets gasoline
here the crazier and more colorful the
cars
the better each rehabbed for a second
chance
and maybe that's part of the appeal for
those who served
they're able to find new life here
like army special ops veteran aj jackson
who says he ended up in a dark
dangerous spiral jackson now finds new
thrills
challenges and rejuvenation racing with
his wife rebecca
as the track shut down for the night we
spoke with the couple
you have somebody who's so driven a team
guy
and it just all went away what have you
seen
in him since he has discovered this kind
of racing he's back
back on track like the over 300 troops
veterans and first responders usmc
racing has put
in the driver's seat the family
environment that's created here a lot of
times it just gives me goose bumps i
don't know what i would do without this
this is my therapy a therapy that's
raising the spirits
and pulses of those who've risked
everything
to keep us safe for cbs this morning
jamie wax on the track in angleton texas
it makes so much sense to me yeah it
does how it could be helpful to get
behind the car like that and just
go and just go i like his wife's face
when she goes he's back
he's back i love that he's racing with
his wife